all right so what's your question i've
been in a relationship with my
girlfriend for like four months now i
feel like everything is going cool
i feel like we don't talk much we we
like hang out like a lot when we do
like hang out it's mostly like we just
don't do like much
talking i feel like there's not a lot
like an interesting topics you know what
i mean
all right i'll preach i'm 20.
you ain't got much to talk about damn
why'd you have to say it like that
that's cold
bro you ain't got much to talk about
there's not much really going on in your
life there's nothing much
like there's nothing you got much to
talk about and it's okay
actually okay wait at 20 years old
you're saying when you were on dates
with your girl you weren't having like
philosophical debates no
and it's okay we have this perception
that everything is like
okay so yeah this i was thinking that
and now sometimes it's just this is what
happened to my date oh honey please
tell me more i'd like to hear all about
it and what did you feel what do you
think the philosophy behind his actions
were
how was your day i went to school [ __ ]
i know i was there
i'm not even trying to diss you some
[ __ ] i'm talking about me
when i was 20 i ain't got much to talk
about i mean i was a dancer so i was
dancing uh track and field
yeah i just i wasn't like making the
extra curricular so i feel like i'm not
like
i'm not like a boring person but wait
you're a boring person
my definition 20 you ain't got really
much going on that's okay
and it's okay just enjoy each other if
it ain't a problem
if it's not a thing like sometimes i
used to go to my girl's house
i said yo what's up you good yeah all
right what you want to do nothing
and we napped there we go for a whole
afternoon nothing sh
that's right sorry hey man listen ask
any 30 year old who's dated a 19 or 20
year old
uh not a single one of them gonna say
that person was super interesting and
it's okay guys you have time to develop
your person it's the same thing for me
when i was at
age so don't be like i'll be trying to
like i go to work all the time i'm just
trying to
y'all started dating through this
pandemic uh yeah
okay and y'all can't do activities i'm
assuming because of where you live
i mean it's are you indoors why you got
your mask on when you're indoors you're
just trying to like hide your faces
yeah yeah i mean okay it's cool it's
like another totally blew his clipper i
didn't know i i didn't know why he was
wearing this man so i had to ask yeah
there's reasons
i didn't want him to actually take him
off i just want to ask the question
that's it he took it off
didn't say take that [ __ ] off did i say
that yeah you did no you didn't
he didn't yeah he took the pressure he's
right i was like don't take chains off
take my ass off how did andy up on
himself yeah i understand
but it's like okay you're 20 you're in
culverd there's nothing going on outside
right we know what's going on outside
it's on the news
yeah the other day a girl's like you
want to go to this event i'm like it's
covered
so i said what do you want to do i'm
like the safest thing is for you to come
to my place
baby i'm doing this for you
hey you know guys you know what i mean
there's nothing going on outside
there's nothing going on in your life
you don't do the extracurricular
activities yep what else it's normal
that you don't say
there's nothing going on i i was just
worried i was like i don't know what
kind of regulations
girlfriend not not [ __ ] oh okay oh
okay
grateful okay okay my bad i didn't know
that that's my bad that's not me all
right i'm gonna apologize to you bro um
y'all started meeting during this
pandemic and you guys can't go on super
interesting dates correct
okay so let's just dive down a bit so
like we could go out to
eating all that but like we haven't been
like theaters and nothing like that
okay how about when you guys are just
chilling together and you guys are in
the same space do you feel good are you
guys
like do you like being around her yeah i
would say like like she
we're like similar and i like really
like her energy or whatever so i feel
like
in in the matters that we're similar
like she also like just doesn't talk
much like we
i feel like she like she's like just
like shy and like i feel that too
because i'm like a shy person so i'm
gonna just say one last thing
you just have to ask yourself do you
feel the need to do all these extra
conversation
is because you want that or is it
because you feel like supposed to
relationships are supposed to be like
that okay there's a difference between
the two
there's a difference between the two all
right because sometimes we come in with
ideas of what relationship's supposed to
look like
okay and then we get something else and
we're like wait it doesn't match this
idea something's wrong something's not
necessarily wrong
you just came in with expectations that
aren't matching feel free
to feel good if you if you look forward
to seeing her
if you like being in the same space as
her i think you're already off to a
great start you feel what i'm saying
yeah so so don't get too caught up in
your head as long as you
like the person that you're with and you
enjoy being around that person
then you've got a strong basis for
everything else all right
all right thanks man i appreciate you
something else
one more thing if you got a girl that is
shy and doesn't want to talk
enjoy that wow phrase that sounded
problematic
same thing for a guy that doesn't want
to talk like enjoy that
enjoy that [ __ ] it's great science is
great yeah i just don't want to talk
like it's cool because when it's like a
kid so whenever you have not comparing
women to kids whatever
like whenever you have a kid you're like
oh i can't wait for that kid to talk and
then that kid starts talking and you're
like
shut the [ __ ] up yeah
i'm uh i'm gonna say this right i
mean you've had this conversation preach
about what but
my favorite thing in a relationship with
when i'm seeing someone
is that when we're sitting together
we're hanging out and it's quiet
if she makes the silence better
for me that's one of the best things in
the world because i know i don't got to
do a whole bunch of stuff or anything
like that we just like being around each
other
like my space is better because you're
there if we meet that criteria
all this extra fluff like man you want
to hear something funny bro sometimes i
go on dates with girls right and then
cool and then we start taking the next
level
okay like we're doing dates to chill
hanging out each other's place you know
making food for each other having good
dinners good sex blah blah blah then we
start talking about leia let's get into
this relationship and all of a sudden
this girl's like talking about so we
should do this activity this activity we
should go here and here i'm like
okay cool but do you do any of that in
your personal life or that stuff that
you've ever wanted to do she's like no
i'm like
then why is it that once you get a
relationship all of a sudden you want to
climb
mount kilimanjaro like you're not a
mountain climber why is all these extra
stuff
but a lot of people have ideas about how
a relationship is supposed to look
and they're reaching for ideas rather
than like yo we got something good
that's you then do you but if it's not
don't try to do not because you feel
like you have to do something it's not
because you're doing something that
you're doing something right
okay sometimes i'm just sitting my girl
sitting next to me we don't talk the
tv's on we're both
on the phone but we just chilling we're
just chilling from our normal days
from our everyday life for her office
for my everyday going everywhere
we just chilling tv's there huh and then
we whenever something's funny on tv like
yeah we have a sparkly little
conversation and then we go back to
whatever just because we want to enjoy
each other's presence
that's it sometimes it's just that come
on
it's just that i feel like people
complicate things a lot and they
self-sabotage
perception that doesn't mean there's not
compromise it doesn't mean like yo if
she's really into something i won't be
willing to do it with her every now and
then that's not what i'm saying
i'm saying why are you trying to behave
as something outside of yourself
when i'm good with who you are me and
you we vibing we
we're chill i don't need a whole bunch
of extra so why is that you trying to
reach for stuff
it's not for me it's not for you so who
are you trying to please
and that's when i get thrown off a
little bit and that's what's going on
with this guy
he's great with her they love going out
to eat they feel great the vibe is
fantastic
but he's like but shouldn't we be having
stimulating conversations
why not necessarily you know so don't be
adding all this extra stuff in this
extra stress it's not necessary don't
complicate your relationship it's okay
to be looking at your relationship like
are we a little boring are you like
maybe and it's okay sometimes you're not
boring you're just not complicated
there you go uncomplicated does not
equate
boredom that's it sometimes i just want
to eat and have good food
where the people out of this food is
good isn't it yes it is
and that's that that's it look at old
couples you think they're out there
being
you know bonnie and clyde all day no
it's chill sometimes they don't even
talk for most of the day but they just
like being in the same space
like home isn't home without this person
being around but it doesn't mean you're
out there chatting each other's ear off
all day
it's not it's not real for most folks
laying in front of the beach
shutting the [ __ ] up and holding hands
and not saying
whoa that's that i'm good we good
i passed out cheap ass uh i passed out
the only conversation that we have the
whole day is
uh you want something to drink about go
get no cool do you want some water
you're good cool
do you need to no all right cool back to
this and that's it that's it that's it
man i could do six hours of that
yeah so don't worry about what hollywood
looks like for leaderships or what
people post on instagram most of the
people posting their lives on instagram
are full of garbage okay
if you're good with that person it's a
binary it's you and her
all right or or her in him whatever the
[ __ ] it is or him and him if you're gay
whatever
doesn't matter or her and her okay all
inclusive or non-binary no you're
missing a bunch of people right now
the the spectrum xangay okay
if you guys are good that's it that's
all that matters don't let other people
get in here like
is that all y'all do y'all don't y'all
don't go out to the you don't get rent a
boat and like go juice
i don't go like it doesn't matter you're
good you're good
you're good that's it man so that'd be
that'd be my personal advice on this
matter there any other pet peeves or
no for no no any advice for married
married couples stop talking
stop talking not stop talking let me
finish god damn it
stop talking and i'm off no just keep
what's in your couple
in your couple okay cause sometimes you
listen to your friends and you don't
listen to
what's going on in your couple you
listen to most of your friends
and not what's going on in your couples
all right or what happened this happened
like even when you tell a story you tell
the story like you're the hero of the
story
they don't have your friends don't have
the perspective right
stop talking about your significant
others
to others because they don't have so
whenever you go back to that person
we don't understand we think you're
trash and we think you regard because
what
are you doing dan you'd be telling me oh
no but you know he's not that bad
they shut the [ __ ] up about that unless
like it's very problematic and you need
help
i'm not saying not talking about that
you're it's being abusive and stuff like
that
that's a different ballgame but little
things like that
talk to your significant uh significant
other there's a lot of y'all out there
that talk more about your couple to your
friends than to your significant other
and that's done
[Music]
is